what is up reject nation you know we're
back here
to watch our man eric vos from new
rockstars
break down give us all the easter eggs
that happened in loki episode one you
know we gotta do it
it's tradition now here anyway if you
guys didn't catch our reaction episode
one go ahead and check that out also i
want to address something that was kind
of just annoying me in the comments
there are people
who are like didn't you guys watch this
so basically people were thinking like
re
re-watch the episode and record a
reaction and try to act like
this was our first time watching it like
what a couple of idiots
do this like two days after the video
that went up on sunday
where we said just watched loki was
recorded after
we recorded the reaction that went up
today and for all the people who think
we watched episode two like a lot of
other people have we have not watched
episode two yet
specifically because we wanted a delight
in stuff like this
with the rest of you guys it was an
intentional choice we made
so we can be part of the audience but
then there's some people who are like
did you guys watch episode 2
well because you know every reaction is
recorded just seconds before it gets
posted
every single you eight to ten
our people on you y'all better be
hitting the like on this one
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel's
loki episode one
in which the god of mischief learns he's
just one infinity stone in a big box
from the many mcu callbacks to a cartoon
i hope you're all taking notes durian
there is so much i know you are
so i'm gonna break this down by shot for
all the cool details that you might have
missed
we opened on new york city 2012 the
scene of loki's escape when we last saw
him in avengers end game
actually this shot is the same exact
establishing shot used in end game
but with the portal beam the chittari
and a few explosions removed now that
the battle's over
and listen to this four note chime the
episode opens with
[Music]
yeah this is directly from the end game
score when tony snuck back into the
tower
notice how the letters flicker and
folding down from the middle just like
the split flap display on old train
station signs
matching the overall analog production
design of the tva
as if they're flipping back to the state
and this prologue now mixes in
alternate tanks from chris evans during
loki's end game arrest
on my way down to coordinate search and
rescue on my way down to coordinate
sergeant rescue
on my way down to coordinate search and
rescue on my way down to coordinate
search and rescue
die there is a little different delivery
yeah cap impression is more robotic
and less of these or yes sir it was an
endgame it's just an example of how we
are already seeing variations to what we
saw before
and although it's not focused on they
kept an ant-man he's still barely
visible running up tony's arm as he
closes
so then downstairs as the fumble
tesseract slides to loki's feet listen
to its sound
and now it's a much fuller coral chime
compared to the sound we heard in
endgame
huh showing how ford loki this tesseract
is still a
sacred key to the god king status that
he seeks but later on as he realizes
this infinity stone is literally
one of an infinite amount of these rocks
that precious hum
fades away
but not knowing that yet loki zips away
with the space stone leaving thor's
voice calling out in the void
where's loki audio also taken from
in-game in the background yeah where's
loki
loki miss panic tells us that loki just
created a disrupted history
displacing himself from his destined
historical path of accompanying thor
back to asgard as he's supposed to
this is why loki is a variant in
violation of the tva's sacred timeline
by teleporting with the space stone he
didn't go back in time or enter any new
reality but
he did warp this history causing it all
to
branch off from the sacred timeline now
of course the avengers also created
branch timelines by taking each stone
but
when cap returned those stones those
branches were erased
however cap returning the tesseract to
1970 would not have erased loki's
theft in 2012 leaving him as the one
lingering paradox that the tv is super
pissed off about
okay but here's a question that now
comes up aren't the avengers partly
responsible for
loki being able to get away then since
they were going for the tesseract it got
kicked away due to the events that they
caused and that they
did not plan properly because that
wasn't supposed to get kicked into
like loki was just standing there he got
kicked
over to him and he walked away with it
yeah it's a variable
in the linear forward motion of the
avengers timeline so it seems like
something that is happening in the
future past not the past
past yeah i mean there are things about
that eric vos has already been pointing
out that i love
especially with sound design being a
part of the storytelling in it of itself
like with the hum of the
tesseract but then these questions do
come up that is addressed in the show in
a sort of way of like
why is this okay but this isn't okay why
am i considered a variant but what the
avengers did that's okay i can cap get
married to peggy
yeah just go back and live in the past
yeah yeah
there's so much to a pack here then the
marvel studios title turns green with a
flash of gold of course the colors of
loki then we find ourselves in
mongolia's gobi desert this cool shot of
an insect crawling reflected
upside down in a droplet of water
recalling this loki's
recent arrogance an ant has no quarrel
with a boot
of course threw back in his face later
in that movie and
boot and now this pompous god is about
to get stomped back down to earth as an
insect compared to the might of the tva
and in this shot the camera pushes
in on loki's crash landing in the sand
recalling the shot of iron man
the first iron man film a similar tale
of an egomaniac forced to reconcile with
his actions
transitioning from a violent villain to
just a mischievous hero
since remember this is the 2012 era loki
not the nicer guy
that he evolved to be in the later films
though this episode does kind of get him
close to it via dramatic home movies but
yes
time variance authority these are the
marvel time cops they prosecute timeline
violators with an army of minutemen foot
soldiers chrono monitors and
judges representing them now is hunter
b15 her scanner labels loki as
variant l one one thirty and notice how
the units
drop from five towards zero meaning
their whole sacred timeline is always
just five whatever these units are away
from branches veering into redline
territory
showing how delicate this timeline
really is the tva's weapons are these
glowing batons which
could be handheld versions of the
retroactive cannon
that the tva uses in the comics to erase
people from existence aka cheesecon
notice how b15s glows violet
unlike the others that glow orange as we
see later orange is the color used to
reset violators to their native timeline
so maybe violet is a setting used to
stun a violator in amazing slow motion
that is such a great move
[Music]
feeling all that pain in real time yikes
she is forcing loki to feel all of this
pain but
dilated out 16 times longer than he
should
punishment via time dilation is actually
a recurring theme on the show black
mirror
in which actress wounmi masaku who plays
hunter b-15
previously tortured wyatt russell's
character in a time
dilated hell so they end up pruning this
timeline with a reset
that's how she got the party's orange
and then turns purple
now previously purple sorcery has been
associated with agatha harkness
before that dormammu in the dark
dimension and in doctor strange remember
timeline reversal like this was
considered a form of dark magic
creator michael waldron wrote the latest
draft of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
and in an interview with mt he teased
that he may have been smart enough to
include these links between the two
titles did you set up anything in loki
episodes that you could cash in later on
in doctor strange the multiverse of
madness or call back anything in doctor
strange from loki i think that's
something
you you'll have to you have to watch it
all and find out
find find out if i was that smart or not
and we'll talk about more of these later
we have an interview with him going up
uh as well and
that dude has knows how to fight his way
through answers now
you can see why phi he's taking such a
liking to him he knows how to answer the
question
so well he keeps you honest and he just
he elevated the character
in in every way should we expect a wow
line from him will he say the word wow
at one point in the show
i keep seeing i keep seeing the memes in
the game and i
and i ask myself i'm like did i is it in
there
i think when the multiverse madness was
announced we thought that would be the
big game changer
but i really feel like it's loki this
will be the one that
really opens up the door and the
possibilities this will be the
the real start of all the craziness of
what multiverse has to offer us
the real pulling back of the curtain to
reveal the wizard yeah
yeah we thought it would be one division
we thought we might have to wait till
multiverse of madness but i think it's
this one right here so we arrive at the
tva
with interiors that are often colored
with eye scorching orange
this color was often used in early 70s
designs to
come off as warm and inviting but now
just come off as cringy and
uncomfortable and tortuous
much like the orange miss minutes
there's how another variant is a
squirrel wearing attraction yeah
of course the shape-shifting race seen
in captain marvel spread rampart from
home one division squirrels are just
gonna start showing up
everywhere as we head towards secret
invasion p15 rewinds loki back to her
with a device later called the time
twister now in the comics the time
twisters are actually beings created by
accident during the creation of the time
keepers they move backward in time and
destroy all on their path here the
device is a remote leash to whomever is
wearing the collar kind of like rick and
morty yeah that episode
yeah the writer was one of the main
writers for rick and morty i remember
when that device was introduced to rick
and morty i was like
that'd be so cool to have that it makes
me wonder how much we're going to see in
this series that
hearkens to rick and morty how much that
show is done with
especially like universe and timeline
hopping it was called like a do-over
machine or something
yeah yeah so it's not exactly the same
thing but it's aesthetically
in my mind did go there there's a nod
comedian josh fedo plays variant named
martin
my dad is on the board of goldman sachs
one with a name like martin i gotta
wonder if he could be based on martin
shkreli but either way
how did this rich brat from earth end up
as a timeline variant could this be
jimmy woo's witness in federal witness
protection who went missing with no
explanation
are we ever gonna get an answer to that
i don't know and then comedian eugene
cordero plays tva clerk named casey
notices pens in his front pocket later
in the episode
the ink will leak more and more into his
shirt
because he has a ton of confiscated
space stones and none of them stored a
stupid tesseract also maybe casey knows
a tesseract is technically a fourth
dimensional hypercube incapable of being
seen by human 3d perception but
he doesn't know what a fish is i love it
i gotta say man like
that pen detail is something that i
would never have caught in a million
years now this is why i love new rock
stars because it's true there's evidence
of it happening right there you can feel
the intention of a production design
absolutely applying that that's
so clever i don't even really know what
the purpose of doing that really is but
it's just it's just a fun little thing
it's just like a magical universal
character detail
yeah juju yeah and he's like not
noticing it he's so naive to it this
whole breakdown so far we're not even
that far in but it's really getting me
to appreciate
more than just like oh here's an easter
egg here's like the actual
filmmaking details you can appreciate
loki meets this pervy d clothing bot who
greets them with a slow
warming smile that ends with the right
eye twitching a bit just a little
unnerving to have the thing
stripping you naked glitch but as we
will see the tva's clockwork is a bit
glitchy in general
the transcript room features a cat who's
also on this guy's
mug or is it a flerkin also i love how
this guy is playing solitaire on his
little orange display when loki dropped
that poor guy his wall clock like all
the clocks we see in the tva features
multiple hands and
more than 12 numbers around the
circumference everything loki has ever
said
is printed out on this dot matrix
printer though as someone who's over a
thousand years old
i would think that stack should be way
larger and then loki gets his body scan
for his temporal
aura which prints out on polaroid film
kind of like a heat index but presumably
for
time almost like instant carbon dating
and the attendant asks
please confirm to your knowledge that
you are not a fully robotic being we're
born an organic
creature and do in fact possess what
many cultures would call a soul
yeah he specifies fully robotic and born
organic because we know cybernetically
reassembled beings like nebula probably
have a soul
i think but also just like this idea
that there are ultron like robots out
there that are trying to pass as organic
life forms bring up an interesting
question that loki asks
do a lot of people not know if they're
robots what if i was a robot and i
didn't know it
yes from loki recalling the
voigt camp test of blade runner that was
used to test ai
replicants who might not even know if
they're robots but i see this as one
first step by loki from
godly arrogance to mortal fear that's
true good point
yeah i gotta say like if from a um from
a scripting standpoint
that moment does register one of my
favorite qualities of this episode was
all the existential identity crises that
uh loki was having to endure
throughout this episode and i love how
with a writer like michael waldron here
he managed to have that moment the
question posed
in a humorous way where you don't
realize that's kind of what's happening
yeah
until it really clicks in the moment
when he questions like the tva the
greatest
yeah but it's been slowly building to
that and deconstructing loki throughout
that is kind of like the start of
asking yourself about your identity well
it's a great joke thing too because it
also like if you were pitched that
information
you would have to stop and probably go
well if i didn't know i wouldn't know so
how do i know yeah
now the next room has this poster
showing miss minutes warning
behave where you'll get your clock
cleaned which is literally what the
minutemen do
with their ret cannons to reset people's
clocks actually there are great tva
posters everywhere
in this place zero tolerance over the
ticket checking window because yeah they
got zero tolerance over whether or not
you got a ticket later there's one
showing a shadowy suited figure reading
always watching you can see a better
shot of it in the credits just a big
brother-y and warning from the high
ranks of the tva another one saying
stable society tidy timeline with a dude
pruning branches and a poor
bird looking at him while he does so
just an example of how the tva doesn't
really care about any worthy light
in new branch timelines that get formed
it's all about the trunk
then tidy cubicle healthy timeline with
branch variants of a clerk at his neat
desk within one redline variant
standing on his desk going nuts yeah the
propaganda prioritizes neatness over
everything else
but of course we get this adorable
animation from tva mascot miss minutes
voiced by strong in a southern accent
kind of like mr dna explaining the
science of jurassic park
yeah mr dna where did you come from
from your blood hey by the way we have a
whole loki inspired
wow oh great yeah i gotta get that and
it shows up quite a bit in which you can
show some worship of six
figures check it out new
rockstarsmerch.com so miss minutes
explains a new mcu history
long ago there was a vast multiversal
war
but then the all-knowing timekeepers
emerged
bringing peace by reorganizing the
multiverse into a single
timeline the sacred timeline
so according to this the mcu used to
exist as a multiverse of timelines
timelines that ward with each other but
the timekeepers interfered with that
natural state deciding to merge
all the timelines into one sacred
timeline and that everything we have
seen in the mcu so far has been a kind
of intermediary peace time
see in the comics the three time keepers
named astavanth and zorth
are creations of he who remains the
final tva agent at the end of all time
to pass on lessons to the next universal
cycle but as neutral time deities these
guys are kind of [ __ ] they at times
partner with folks like immortus aka
kang the conqueror to wage conflict with
the avengers so this tva slogan of for
all time always
is at least somewhat a lie like it
hasn't been always
there was a whole other stage of the
universe where things were multiverse so
this is really a myth
cooked to inflate
authority narrative commission proving
that they have
an in-house propaganda department this
whole thing is like the big brother
ministry of truth but back to the
cartoon the power
in deep space maybe we're seeing the
aftermath of a conflict among the
celestials
because we know from the severed head of
the celestial nowhere that some war
caused that
maybe they're going to go with comics
and save the symbiote null decapitated
him but i think the celestials are going
to be involved with it and then we
follow some animation inspired by rocky
bullwinkles specifically the mr peabody
and sherman shorts
we're all this yellow man and a bow tie
whose variants toggle from a sea captain
to this brute to a mug
to a mad scientist to a top hat guy but
notice how each
incorporates his bow tie he's still
essentially the same snob
and if this does represent loki we do
later see loki and a turtleneck from
trailer footage and that
platform could be loki as jack the
ripper maybe another real world mystery
that loki could have been behind the way
he was d.b cooper
that would be so sadistic if you that
was jack there would have been a part
to justify the mo
and the letters loki i have another bet
for you
yeah prostitutes you have to kill all
these prostitutes and white holes
i hope they go for it man that is uh
freaking mind-blowing i didn't think
about it in the context of what he was
talking about at all
that it isn't all time it isn't the
beginning is that they
there was a multiverse already and then
the timekeepers
they condensed it all into the one
timeline
the one that has to be obeyed yeah so
it's like was a show gonna end with like
when we're talking about multiverse of
madness and then
the loki variants causing all this
trouble is that gonna cause the events
of the sacred timeline to branch off
into multi i feel like it's gonna happen
with this
with this show i can see it because i
mean they've made
in the first episode already importance
of the sacred timeline and that seems
like such a
fragile mcguffin spiderman maybe the
multiverse is
already breaking around him and then
yeah obviously dr
strange it certainly seems like that
level of event and plus what a bold way
to end a show like this you introduce us
to the tva
it's a magical but also foreboding world
and then by the end maybe it's left in
ruins
yeah and then we also see this yellow
man leading some kind of
uprising in a battle involving a race
that looks a bit like the cree
meanwhile the ships on the right look a
lot like the ruins of titan
thanos's home world that we saw infinity
war so maybe this
uprising is against the titan colony of
eternals that thanos's father elars
established and then miss minutes goes
on
stepping off your path created a nexus
event
which left unchecked could branch off
into madness
leading to another multiversal war
nexus events reminding us how one
division defined the scarlet witch as a
nexus being a character from the marvel
comics with the ability to rewrite
reality serving as a linchpin
bridging their reality with others and
by saying branch off into madness
leading to another multiversal war
yeah i think it's a strong sign that
this sacred timeline here could be
doomed
to unravel leading to a repeat of the
historical cycle in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness in which wanda search for her
children
just make sure you have your ticket and
you'll be seen by the next available
attendant yeah notice thomas minutes is
an extreme close-up here
just a very stern warning signaling just
how seriously they take tickets
and martin says well you're raising your
voice with me bucket head
yeah i love that they kept in favor's
little stammer on the word raising
and martin gets horrifically reset and
loki shows this ticket like all the
passengers in indiana joins the last
crusade now the loki title letters
flicker in with a white
glow on this black background and at one
point the o has
little horns like loki's oh neato
that's true 1549 tva agent mobius owen
wilson
is based on mobius in mobis in the
comics we also heard the word mobius
back in
end game when tony stark figured out
time travel in the
shape of a mobius strip inverted please
now some mystery killer lured in these
minutemen here to
steal their reset charge using an
anachronistic
item dropped in the past in this case
kablooey gum given to a kid
to say cafe
the moment we've all been waiting for
you to talk about devil's afraid of
us yeah i'm gonna get this out of the
way no no this is not me
serious creators confirmed it it's
really just meant to reflect
loki as a horned ambitious god like
lucifer cast out of his heaven
we get a further clue when mobius is
handed
don't try to just move past that super
quick yeah i see you trying to be all
nonchalant yeah
see all you breakdown easter egg people
just being like look it's it's not
it's not give us credit we're not gonna
make that mistake again it was credit
for
i said it's not in the film no and the
filmmaker said it's
it's not what i want is the footage of
eric voss between the moment he saw that
shot and the moment that quote was
released
were you really in knowledge of that
yeah or did you need clarification
you gotta admit boss you thought for a
second
maybe mephista maybe something maybe
validation
in the form of a stained glass waiting
yes i agree
it's loki that's what it is with the
horn yeah she's pointing at
little girl but a lot of us did go maybe
mephisto
i think it's okay to admit that we get a
further clue when mobius is handed loki
variant l130s rap sheet
it's all listed out here he is loki
lauthyssen because he was actually born
son of laufey the frost giant from
jutenheim before becoming odin's ward
thus his alias of odinson
his sex is listed as fluid
so this is a huge confirmation of the
theories that we've had for over a year
now that the alternate loki that they
are chasing is in fact
a female form probably played by sophia
di martino most likely going to be lady
loki now in the comics
lady loki isn't really an alternate
timeline loki but rather a post
female body intended for a reincarnated
soul of lady sif
but instead possessed by the soul of
loki now this episode did clarify that
logan has a
soul but i think they're gonna be using
timeline logic instead
because somehow that's simpler in the
courtroom are murals depicting figures
with red sashes and legal scale these
must be the tva
judges and one of those judges with his
glasses and his mustache
looks kind of like a younger stan lee
other murals show tva clerks and
technicians these could be the chrono
monitors and the army of minutemen and
on the other side the timekeepers
overseeing the sacred timeline and
presiding over loki's case with the
three time keeper faces looming behind
is
justice ravona rinslayer google mubatara
who in the comics is associated with
kang the conqueror one of the many
reasons i have been speculated this
time-traveling villain confirmed to come
up in ant-man in the wats quantomania
played by jonathan majors
might show up in this show loki casts
blame on the avengers oh believe me you
can smell the cologne of two tony starks
a callback to ant-man making fun of
tony's scent is that
axe body spray yeah i had a can on the
desk for emergencies relax
and mobius shows loki that tva the vast
grid of spires and platforms all with
numerical designations it was et282
this all seems to go on forever likely
the used version of the null time zone
the tva home dimension that's removed
from time and space and loki responds by
saying
this place is a nightmare what's another
department now that department i'll help
you burn down
now what would these time cops care
about people's nightmares
unless maybe their power comes from
another dimension where cosmic beings
like
nightmare reside nightmare being a
cosmic entity in the marvel mechanics a
villain to dr strange
who could show up in the second dr
strange movie but i also like the theory
that maybe when things are ret cannoned
they live on in people's subconsciouses
and that's where nightmares come from
now the elevator buttons all correspond
to three characters
i like that i don't seem to refer to
anything specific yet but i think it's
just a sign of how complex
and do we decimal like the different
floors of the tva are though
in the end credits when these appear on
the screen the code
1ej is immediately hit with access
denied so there is some part of the tva
that is off limits now in the time
theater mobius sips adjusta
a discontinued soft drink from the late
90s similar to that goku fruit juice
that we've seen in the trailer footage
the tba might be able to access all the
food and drinks that you can't get
anymore and in this interrogation loki
explains why he wanted to rule
i would have made it easy for them the
first and most oppressive
lie ever uttered was the song of freedom
yes connecting to his speech in germany
which mobius actually shows him among
his greatest hits in the tva hollow
projector
the bright lure of freedom diminishes
your life's
joy in a mad scramble for power now
mobius reminds loki about agent coulson
oh yeah phil coulson
can the avengers come together to
literally avenge him
if you believe that whole sacred
timeline explanation this could be
another nail in the coffin of agents of
shield's canonicity since that show
assumes coulson did not really die
though don't worry if this ends with a
sacred timeline blowing up into a
multiverse
one of those alternate timelines could
just be the one agent's shield is all
set in so
we're still we're still good i think
there was one thing i was actually
catching on twitter today and i didn't
really know exactly why people were
arguing about it but then yeah bringing
it back up here in the show i'm like
that's true they did not talk at all
about what happened with coulson after
avengers and how he like lived on an
agent of shield i think like with the
multiverse we don't know for sure
but let's say charlie cox as daredevil
is in fact
in no way home no way home and we have
characters from the other spider-man
movies
confirmed to be in here let's let agents
of shield live on as part of this
multiverse
yeah let us pay off a few of those
rumors yeah come on let it happen man
even though kevin feige clearly wanted
not much to do with any of that notice
how the battle of new york highlights
freeze on the waitress
beth that character played by ashley
johnson chrissy saver from growing pain
birthplace of ralph poner take a look at
this
jesus christ that was a cat subplot that
was cut from that first avengers movie
or we can now look at it as a pruned
branch storyline that mobius could be
interested in
and we learned loki was real life
mystery hijacker db cooper
yeah william scott was actually the name
of the pilot of that northwest orient
305 in 1971
when db cooper or someone using that
alias hijacked a flight and jumped out
of the plane with 200 000
and stolen cash notice how here heimdall
catches loki via the bifrost leaving
some cash floating
a nod to the fact that all they ever
found of db cooper was some cash
floating in the columbia river
it was all loki all along
but it was all because loki apparently
lost a bet to thor
who's all in on this just a reminder of
how much of a reckless jerk thor used to
be
now as mobius helps loki up you can see
the moment look his eyes when he spots
the time twister in his pocket and
notice how his swipe is distracting oh
just would be interesting because
according to the end game directors cap
living his life with peggy created a
branch timeline what the tva might now
consider to be a variant nexus violation
though really the variant perpetrator in
that case would be old steve not his
poor wife so i don't know so loki sneaks
off and finds casey who returns to
tesseract and reveals a whole evidence
drawer filled with variant infinity
stones here we go
how do you have these oh we actually got
a lot of those
some of the guys use them as paper
weights some of them so how do they get
these
well maybe each variant they've caught
may have been in possession of an
infinity stone
since the ancient ones seem to suggest
that only the removal of stones could
cause branches from the sacred timeline
and maybe with each pruning the stolen
stone was just restored back to the
sacred timeline leaving this stone in
the tva as a kind of powerless carbon
copy receipt of it now in this box you
can see
red reality stones green time stones
purple power stones blue space stones a
couple chunky orange soul stones though
interestingly no yellow mine stones
available
and then loki picks up a time stone as
if of all these the one he would want
the most is the ability to reverse time
also in this drawer is a super rare t206
bonus wagner baseball card
a casino chip for 5 000 and some kind of
military medal and then later in the end
credits you can actually see a mind
stone being used as a paperweight i also
have to wonder what casey meant by
some of the agents use the infinity
stones as paperweights could some past
dva agent have snatched one of these
went into the timeline
and started wreaking havoc to become
kang i'm gonna go with that explanation
hang gang for life okay wait a minute so
basically wha what was he saying
i think this was a moment that did not
fly by well with a lot of people
uh who watched it i'm not saying a
majority but i think there's a lot
especially i saw it reflected in the
comments of like
nat died for nothing yeah yeah you watch
all these movies lead up to the infinity
stones that apparently
they're not even th they don't even hold
as much power as we thought they did but
what
eric was saying because they're from a
variant
they're probably the yeah
duplicate design but it's it's like a
fraud it's a fugazi
it's something like or maybe it's like
yeah it's like somebody steals a stone
creates a branch timeline
and then once that timeline is righted
and the stone is put back
yeah maybe like the physical copy just
like loses its mojo
would that explain why would the
tesseract loki doesn't try to
whoosh on out of there like the the test
track doesn't work here
is that why the stones don't work that's
my guess jazz that if this is
the same kind of realm suspended outside
of time and space i guess the rules
you know it's like if the stones create
the faculties of the known universe and
all
those you know things coming together in
a place that exists
completely beyond all that you know yeah
i can't imagine i guess that the stones
would be
of much consequence here but they are
clearly to the sacred timeline
so i think yeah it's got to have
something to do with the fact that it's
outside the timeline
yeah so it's not that it's undercutting
the power of the stones
yeah because in reality where all of us
live they are
still quite powerful and key to
maintaining what we understand as
reality
if i'm understanding this yeah yeah
while since i've been like really use
your brain power to keep up with the
boss today
yeah this one you gotta engage with as
well yeah just gonna feed it to us
b15 finds loki tries to reset him but
instead erases casey's evidence cart
showing that in addition to the variants
people and things in the tba can be
rhett cannon to
somewhere loki scrubs back through
frigga's death with this interesting
music plane
[Music]
this amazing mournful violin melody was
composed by the loki composer natalie
holt who is clearly very talented though
i gotta mention this because it's
amazing she used to work as a backup
musician on britain's got talent and she
freaking egged simon cowell for ruining
the music industry
a freaking badass loki also more into
odin
i love you my sons yeah focusing on one
of my favorite details from thor
ragnarok tom hiddleston's reaction to
odin finally considering loki a son
and finally loki arrives at his death
yeah the framing makes it look like
future loki is saying this to
our variant loki like the ghost of
christmas future telling him to let go
of his god king ambitions
and then notice as the film strip runs
out on the hollow projector it reads
tail one one two nine one four i think
seven one one two nine one four
loki laufey sin meaning this is the tail
end of the film reel but the weird thing
is in the close-up of the film strip as
it goes across the projector reel it
says tail
1 eth 616 180 th616 loki loftison and i
only point that out because 616 is the
numerical designation
of the prime marvel universe in the
comics technically the mcu
is earth19999 so loki isn't confessing
to mobius
i don't enjoy hurting people it's
part of the illusion so loki even back
in 2012 was never a sadist he's just a
mischievous
scamp who commits violence in order to
gain power he's projecting an illusion
of his fearsomeness and that is the
confirmation mobius has been
wanting with all this questioning really
this is all a voigt camp test to
determine if loki had any humanity in
him
and now that mobius knows what he does
he gives loki this assignment a chance
to destroy the worst parts of himself
the variant we're hunting is you
and so the epilogue goes to an oil field
in selena oklahoma in 1858 for hunter
you
92 investigates this interesting device
time signature is early third millennium
definitely anachronistic early third
millennium would be
now i guess do you think first
millennium is zero to your thousand
second millennium is one thousand to two
thousand so early third millennium would
be sometime between
two thousand and twenty three hundred i
guess anyway it is a sign that we are
looking at some villain with
access to future technology and here is
our hooded villain
our evil loki variant burning them all
in hell fire as that stained glass
demon foretold actually in that art
there is a moon which to me recalls the
trailer footage of sophia dimartino's
character
in the shadow of a collapsing moon who
is she exactly
we will find out now the end credit
sequence is filled with cool visual
details so many that i actually have to
break it down in a separate video
but a few things i got to note here
among some math pinned to an office wall
is an equation whose name is partially
obscured but it looks like
schrodinger's equation i'm not certain
if this is actually shorter nearest
equation
quantum physics nerds forgive me if it
isn't he's one of the early theoretical
physicists who really pioneered quantum
mechanics that loki's branch timeline
logic is really based on
jordan of course famous for his
schrodinger cat thought experiment in
which an unobserved cat is both alive
and dead simultaneously essentially
saying we all kind of exist in separate
realities
there's an apocalyptic event describing
the events of the d.b cooper hijacking
from seattle 1971.
just interesting that the tva
categorizes that as an apocalyptic event
just make me think that they might
consider it on par with events like the
destruction of pompeii
which we also will see in this series
there's also a variant diagram
showing five different variants there's
one with the circle head and then the
other heads show the second layer a
triangle pentagon hexagon and then an x
just like the number of variants we saw
the yellow cartoon guy have
and then the credit visuals end with the
faces of the timekeepers of the
courtroom punching in specifically on
the center one before cutting to black
which i have said before
does look a bit like the face of
jonathan majors who's gonna play kang
and interesting that kang's lover ravana
rinslayer was framed directly in that
figure's
lips and lastly if you stick around all
the way to the end of the credits you
can hear the voice of who
miss minutes coming back thanks for
visiting the tva
don't hesitate to let us know how we're
doing and after this great first episode
i think you guys are doing great
another reminder to support this channel
by checking out our great loki inspired
merch options
merch.com follow me on instagram twitter
follow new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for breakdowns of everything
loki thanks for watching bye
what will we do without this i remember
when we were watching his trailer
breakdowns those 25-minute trailer
breakdowns
and i'd be like oh my god my head cannot
process everything that is being told to
me right now we're back here again
yes going damn this does not work well
off four hours of sleep
this is almost as long as the episode
it's basically
i'm gonna have to keep track of a lot
and then with time travel
and multiverses it's only gonna get
easier
all right guys well new rock stars
you guys really are the rock stars wow
wow you said this was coming out this
afternoon
or later on today came out around close
to 6 p.m
our time much later than when you
normally upload and then after seeing
this epic breakdown
i totally get why that was
incredibly put together kudos to the
whole new rockstars team
subscribe to them you can check out our
loki video hit that like button keep a
lookout for an interview last but not
least
adelia chamberlain loki
i have it on good authority is your
favorite or at least among your top
favorite mcu characters in this video
actually got me thinking of you knowing
we would do probably a shout out i was
like who would our patreon
would fit right in at a place like the
time variance authority i feel like it
would be you i mean imagine
your knack for creating worlds i could
see you also keeping them in line you
know enforcing
that sacred timeline with your wit with
your cleverness
you're even getting like more out there
with your persona and your colorful
vibes that you put out i just hope
you're doing well and i hope that the
structure of time and space in your life
is holding
together together nicely and i hope that
you're enjoying the show because
honestly
i mean you've got to be more excited
than anybody for something like this
and uh if we're pleased i hope you're
because if you're not pleased and that
means our opinions are just wrong
so anyway thanks for all the love and
support adelia
love you adelia